hello Felix hello hello fine thank you
fine thank you and how are you they're
in Brussels okay you know what what
interests me is you know this world of
polyglots on the internet it's very
interesting there's a group of us that
regularly strut our stuff so to speak
you and Moses and and Richard and and
Luca and others but there's many more
who don't appear on YouTube
I had a tweet from a fellow in
Alexandria had a bunch of exotic Arabic
script which I can't read but he said
come on down to Alexandria I'll brew up
some coffee and we can speak in French
and Italian and whatever and when are
you gonna learn Arabic and I just think
it's a wonderful it's a wonderful
community and it's I think the big
message is we can all learn many
languages I really believe that what do
you think I would say for other
languages huge problems learn them
because we know how to learn actually
it's the way to learn that we discover
the years right although in looking at
your videos I mean we will have some
minor areas of disagreement because to
some extent not disagreement but I think
we all recognize that every person is
gonna find their own path you know to
get from A to B we all get to B but some
people meander a little bit over there
and some people meander a little bit
over here but I think the basic
principles are the same but let me ask
you a question I was reading a blog
which is written by my Russian teacher
at link who lives in the Ukraine and she
has a blog in Russian about language
learning and it just so happened that
this morning this morning I was reading
her blog and she said that there
studied on that show the Chinese in
Chinese the distinction between the verb
and the noun is less clear than in
English and therefore the brain operates
differently and therefore when Chinese
people go to learn English they don't
have make this clear distinction that a
lot of detailed stuff about how the
brain deals with different languages so
I want to begin by asking you because
you speak Asian languages and European
languages and so do i and I was never
conscious of the problem that my brain
might have and jumping from one language
to another have you found this to be an
issue at all and then jumping to Turkish
writers of similarities of grammar I
found it very useful I felt like a
second Japanese I thought I said in my
latest video right that I'd learn like
when I learned Japanese actually I know
the kanji in Chinese because I'd learned
the traditional form way of writing but
my brain is still thinking in Japanese I
don't read the can't cheat in Chinese
yeah it's a bit weird to explain when I
read in Japanese even if I know how to
pronounce the character in Chinese I
don't read it in Chinese in my head it's
in Japanese
okay no all right let's step back then
you're the language is like ah if you
say okay Chinese French English Spanish
which of these four languages do you
speak the best
okay so if French is a hundred where is
Chinese presumably Mandarin I don't know
if you speak Taiwanese as well but let's
say Mandarin so French is 100 where is
Mandarin English and Spanish roughly
I don't know actually Chinese I was
forced to learn Chinese because my
father want my dad wanted me to learn
Chinese to be able to communicate when I
would go back to Taiwan right and to be
able to read so I did not experience any
let's say love with Chinese right and
it's my second language but so I did not
read a lot in time he said just now just
read what I have to read for my Janet at
Chinese classes right so my Chinese is
not that good it's not that bad it's a
little bit boring like nice people
Taiwanese people or with Chinese people
they they know that I'm not from Taiwan
or China right so what would it be
better or worse than your English like
to me your English really pretty close
to anyway that but Mike the reason I ask
that is because this article seem to
suggest that someone who who say grows
up as as we did speaking in English
like at another English like I'm
European language that our brains would
be structured differently than someone
who grew up from China from you know
infancy speaking Chinese and that
therefore that's an obstacle as you try
to go from the one Latin language group
to the other and I must say that I
didn't find that because Chinese has its
difficulties but it's just it's just a
collection of patterns and once I get
used to those patterns I'm happy Russian
with all of the complicated case endings
and you know imperfect divin perfective
verbs and to my mind is more complex
than Chinese the biggest problem with
Chinese was just learning the characters
yeah and and learning to pronounce the
tones but insofar as the structure of
the language you know nouns versus verbs
or any of that stuff like I don't think
in those terms at all and I so I I feel
that whatever research they did to show
that you know
Chinese people would be our Chinese
speakers at the end of disadvantage
learning a European language or vice
versa that has not been my experience
and that's why I was thinking you know
in terms of hopping back and forth
between a European language and say
Chinese just because Japanese again is
different but I didn't I don't feel that
that our brains are at a disadvantage it
may very well be that a European
language is more difficult you know if
Chinese were written without the
characters it would be an in fact an
easy language to learn they are leading
on Chinese to learn English or they are
leading on English to learn any other
language so the thing is that we have to
just try to learn a language without
being in another language right don't
compare languages it becomes easier to
learn a second or a third language
typing yeah I don't have to compare if
we compare it's not going to work right
on the other hand as you say if you have
either vocabulary or structural
similarities between languages and
that's going to help you so I'm very
encouraged to hear that your Japanese
help your Turkish that makes me want to
go out and learn Turkish yes so yeah
interesting okay and I saw in your
videos that you like using Pimsleur get
started and then you move on to a Cemile
and so and then and then from there what
do you do there big like cheeks a little
bit my technique actually I used him
slur for Japanese because I had to feel
I had to without expressive develop a
feel for the language by hearing it and
at the beginning I have to learn very
basic words and Pimsleur was helping
although it was a little bit boring
always repetitive but I think it was
good to learn Japanese and then when I
move on to Turkish I did not use pencil
ER because I I had this
any structure in my head who's I could
just easily change it and just think in
Japanese when I've learned Turkish
mm-hmm and then after SEO I would
typically move on and try to read
magazines I read magazines a lot in
Turkish and it helped me a lot and the
newspaper and to accumulate new words
but if you read magazines now are you
looking the words up or how are you
getting the word yeah actually I'm lying
all the words I don't know and maybe at
the beginning I have 50 words maybe 60
words per article but it's it's not an
issue I just look it up on internet and
I I have I just have I just write it
like like for enough an article I will
write it like that right just list of
vocabulary but not to study in the list
just to to write it and to have some
sort of a mental image of the word and
then I would read it again and it's much
clearer when I get the meeting and then
I would let it just let the text for
maybe two days then I just go back and
read it once read it after it just read
it once again then one week after just
repeating and then I think when you read
related articles the words are always
coming again and again and eventually
get used to reading that word and then
the problem is to come convert from
passive to active actually other words
like a cutting and interpreter caffeine
and I was like when I am I going to use
the word passion and Turkish I say okay
it's it's not fair and the point is not
about wandering when I will use that
word and the point is just learn a lot
of vocabulary and you'll see you will
learn and you'll eventually use it but
you don't know when actually I went
hungry and you have to create those
opportunities when where you can
actually use the words you learned in
your input sessions so what I went on a
plane and I was thinking of which word I
could use with uh with the Turkish
hospice and I was seeing are they had
some Cushing's there and that just said
could you get me a cushy in Turkish and
then I used the word caching once and
then when you use it twice your brain
gets to it converts from acid into
active know how much of the word yeah no
I I think that's an interesting point
that that I mean we all want to speak
yeah that's the goal we all want to get
there if we don't have a lot of words
then it's difficult to say anything so I
tend to agree with you I tend to work
very heavily on developing up my passive
vocabulary and when the need arises and
when you're put in a situation where you
need to use the language you stumble you
look for words but eventually as the
need and the opportunity arises all of
that passive vocabulary I find starts to
come but there are things that we can do
I think to to you know improve our
ability to speak but ultimately if you
if you were to go to Istanbul and spend
a you know a couple of weeks there you
know all your hard work in terms of
building up this vocabulary is all of a
sudden gonna bear fruit so to speak yeah
oh you were there yep nice yeah yeah
maybe I went there one week in high
school or maybe more than 20 hours Wow
like I could just sit next to a Fisher
and just say hello how are you and they
will try to strike a conversation and
there are very different from Russells
here is kind of weird if you try to
speak
but someone you don't know right it's
very normal right yeah yeah no I must
say two different people different
national groups you know they react
differently when you say you know I
found for example with Chinese people
they're very welcoming if you speak
their language
Koreans are a little bit more
standoffish depends who you heal you
managed to you know happen to meet some
people are you know some nationalities
that just strangers they kind of stay
away from them but so it depends it
depends one quick comment I'm I ten per
I have often said this I prefer not to
use pimp sir because of all the English
is on there recording so I don't like
doing it I also don't like the fact that
they force you to speak I don't like
being forced to speak I also have not a
big fan of s email because I try to
acquire words where I was asked email
forces you to look at a whole
translation of the text so then if I'm
missing a word I gotta go looking
through the translation to find the word
I would rather have either as you're
doing look up each individual word which
is easier to do on the internet so I you
know whereas to have to pour through a
translation to find the meaning I just
I'm not but that's just me I I would say
that a lot of people like them spirit
and SML I'm happier just go after teach
yourself for colloquial or I start up at
link as I did with check check you know
on but like you I want to get to the
magazines or books or newspapers or the
authentic material as soon as I can and
then teach yourself but I don't like
teachers so I learned my Spanish through
teacher self French perk him up teach
yourself it's cold up up Semitic belong
here oh yeah and learn a lot but I don't
like teach yourself because it's always
a situation like you want to know how to
order coffee you want to know how teach
yourself is not quite no I wouldn't say
that's necessarily true for something
which is ok young when you open a
teacher self you know the first lesson
will be about hello are you are I don't
know very basic things
but you know I kind of feel that I mean
it doesn't matter whether it's teach
yourself or colloquial or is email to me
the first couple of months you've got to
cover that basic stuff one way or
another so it almost doesn't matter and
I will typically before we had link like
I'll just go out and buy teach yourself
and colloquial and cover cover the same
material and you know two different
directions because you just have to at
first the language just sounds like
noise so you have to develop so it's not
very interesting some as you can do to
make it interesting in the initial
period I find but but it's just that
it's so exciting the initial discovery
of the new language is so exciting that
that kind of maintains my interest even
though the actual content that I'm
reading or listening to isn't very
interesting but I hope to get out of
that within a couple of months so some
people that you go for graded readers
and they want everything to be just a
little little bit a little bit more
difficult more difficult which is
perhaps ideal but I find it very often
that means uninteresting content so I
tend to move to to a content of interest
as as as soon as I can
but then we all have when I when I learn
Japanese I would typically read
something where I would search for look
look at a lot of words but the topic is
interesting to me something where I
don't have to look up that many words
but it's not interesting to write I
would not be like motivated to read it
10 times or 15 times so I would I would
just try to choose some interesting
content that's very important no how
many languages do I mean you're
obviously much younger than I am ahaha
what's your goal how many languages do
you want to learn actually I don't have
a fixed goal I think it's it's it's
evolving and I don't choose I don't
actually choose languages I didn't I
didn't know I would learn Turkish and it
just came to me and actually the funny
thing is that it was that Japanese
that recommended me circus mm-hmm and I
like why like why do you want me to
learn Turkish I was like okay I wasn't
learning polish at that time but I just
stopped polish because I did not find a
lot of natives around me and I find I
don't know I didn't have to have any
feel the right vibe with the Polish so I
I started with Turkish and yeah I'm here
I learn Turkish for about two years and
I think I'm going to to carry on
studying Turkish and Arabic no actually
I learn the language when I find a
community I find a Turkish community I
learned Turkish and it's easier to
practice on a daily basis or on a weekly
basis there that's a and I find it very
hard to learn small language or a very
rare language like let's say Adam army
and yeah it's going to learn Armenian
I'll eventually get discouraged because
I don't have natives around me and I
cannot get in touch with the culture
right and when we're speaking about
Turkish I went to Turkish parties I
could see how people greet each other
and you can learn the real language
right but but to be fair you know I
think we all agree that people have
different motives for learning languages
and I mean I have had no contact with
any Czech people here in Vancouver and
I'm having getting tremendous enjoyment
out of reading about Czech history and
and so forth and discovering the
language and of course I do talk to our
some of our tech tutors and I'm going to
go to Prague in October but I mean Moses
for example studies all kinds of remote
you know Moses right he studies all
these not obscure languages but McCallum
minor languages and so so I think people
can have different different interests
and so I
I feel in language honey doesn't matter
whether you're going depth or whether
you just do them a little bit where do
you do them because you like to
socialize or whether you do them because
you're interested in in discovering
Armenian I mean it might be very
interesting I don't know mom or
something whatever like it's all
different manifestations of the human
you know experience so I think we can
all have different different goals
listen maybe we'll stop now and we'll
have because of the other discussions I
had with Richard and with Luca we didn't
really get into any Asian languages so
maybe we'll speak for a while in Chinese
so I'm sure we could talk for another
three hours but I think we have to stop
here and we'll we'll switch over to
Chinese so I'm going to stop the
recording and we'll start up again okay
bye for now and thank you and here Steve